hi there just some donations i don't
know
in west london the donations keep coming
compassion piling up okay i think that
one one small one small one
communities are clearly doing their bit
but is the government doing it
well over half of us don't think so
57 say sanctions should go further a
sentiment felt strongly here
i think people are people are getting
frustrated i think yes let the
government do more come on it's about
time you know the government is
balancing a fine line between providing
the right support and stopping the war
coming into europe um but i really think
that there is more that they could do
that they should be doing
and for those with friends there it's a
matter of emotion we need to do the
right thing
if that means that we will pay more that
our bills will go up that our food price
will go up
it sucks but i'm willing to suck it up
but while that view is reflective
there's a sense people are anxious
in fact while a huge eighty percent of
people said they'd support abound on the
import of russian oil and gas just look
what happens when weighted against
likely cost implications
55 percent would either strongly or tend
to support it if it meant a higher cost
of living
and that would likely be the result of
any ban on buying russian gas
people are already facing historic price
rises even the willing are wary
i've got a pub so it's affecting our
business people don't like it when you
have to put your prices up but yes
it's not fair at the moment but you know
the price is what we're in i don't
understand
cost of living my daughter's schools
school shoes they've just warmed in you
know you're barely just getting by each
month the moment you've got paid you
know it's like making it all stretch
there was a generational divide too
older people more likely to want to go
further more willing to pay for the
fallout
more people might support tougher
sanctions even if it will cost them they
also overwhelmingly support the idea
that the government could act to
mitigate some of that pain things like
higher welfare payments are cut in taxes
or a deferral to the planned rise in
national insurance clearly a sense that
people don't want to be left alone to
shoulder the burden of doing more that
was heavy that may well be noted by a
chancellor already under pressure to
help households in his spring statement
next week
people clearly care
the question is whether they can bear
the cost that brings helen ann smith sky
news